- [Voiceover] What I
wanna do in this video
is a few examples that test our intuition
of the derivative as a rate of change
or the steepness of a curve
or the slope of a curve
or the slope of a tangent line of a curve
depending on how you actually
want to think about it.
So here it says F prime of five
so this notation, prime
this is another way of saying
well what's the derivative
let's estimate the derivative
of our function at five.
And when we say F prime
of five this is the slope
slope of tangent line
tangent line at five
or you could view it as the
you could view it as the rate of change
of Y with respect to X
which is really how we define slope
respect to X of our function F.
So let's think about that a little bit.
We see they put the point
the point five comma F
of five right over here
and so if we want to estimate
the slope of the tangent line
if we want to estimate the
steepness of this curve
we could try to draw a line
that is tangent right at that point.
So let me see if I can do that.
So if I were to draw a line starting there
if I just wanted to make a tangent
it looks like it would
do something like that.
Right at that point that looks to be
about how steep that curve is
now what makes this an
interesting thing in non-linear
is that it's constantly changing
the steepness it's very low
here and it gets steeper
and steeper and steeper
as we move to the right
for larger and larger X values.
But if we look at the point in question
when X is equal to five
remember F prime of five
would be if you were estimating it
this would be the slope of this line here.
And the slope of this line it looks like
for every time we move
one in the X direction
we're moving two in the Y direction.
Delta Y is equal to two when
delta X is equal to one.
So our change in Y
with respect to X
at least for this tangent line here
which would represent our change in Y
with respect to X right at that point
is going to be equal to
two over one, or two.
And it's almost estimated,
but all of these are way off.
Having a negative two derivative
would mean that as we increase
our X our Y is decreasing.
So if our curve looks something like this
we would have a slope of negative two.
If having slopes in this
a positive of point one
that would be very flat
something down here
we might have a slope closer to point one.
Negative point one that
might be closer on this side
now we're sloping but very close to flat.
A slope of zero, that would be
right over here at the bottom
where right at that moment as we change X
Y is not increasing or decreasing
the slope of the tangent line
right at that bottom point
would have a slope of zero.
So I feel really good about that response.
Let's do one more of these.
So alright, so they're
telling us to compare
the derivative of G at four
to the derivative of G at six
and which of these is greater
and like always, pause the video
and see if you can figure this out.
Well this is just an exercise
let's see if we were to
if we were to make a line
that indicates the slope there
you can do this as a tangent line
let me try to do that.
So now that wouldn't,
that doesn't do a good job
so right over here at
that looks like a
I think I can do a better job than that
no that's too shallow to see
not shallow's not the
word, that's too flat.
So let me try to really
okay, that looks pretty good.
So that line that I just drew
seems to be indicative of
the rate of change of Y with respect to X
or the slope of that curve
or that line you can
view it as a tangent line
so we could think about what
its slope is going to be
and then if we go further down over here
this one is, it looks like it is
steeper but in the negative direction
so it looks like it is steeper for sure
but it's in the negative direction.
As we increase, think of it this way
as we increase X one here
it looks like we are
decreasing Y by about one.
So it looks like G prime of four
G prime of four, the derivative
when X is equal to four
is approximately, I'm estimating it
negative one
while the derivative
here when we increase X
if we increase X by
if we increase X by one
it looks like we're
decreasing Y by close to three
so G prime of six
looks like it's closer to negative three.
So which one of these is larger?
Well, this one is less negative
so it's going to be
greater than the other one
and you could have done this intuitively
if you just look at the curve
this is some type of a sinusoid here
you have right over here the curve is flat
you have right at that moment
you have no change in Y with respect to X
then it starts to decrease
then it decreases at an even faster rate
then it decreases at a faster rate
then it starts, it's still decreasing
but it's decreasing at
slower and slower rates
decreasing at slower rates
and right at that moment
you have your slope of
your tangent line is zero
then it starts to increase,
increase, so on and so forth
and it just keeps happening
over and over again.
So you can also think about
this in a more intuitive way.